[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want
oh you did [ __ ] that runs whatever
next month we're trying to make you guys
calm no I want to give a [ __ ] I got for
free days in October first weekend of
October yeah you said okay I want to go
to the fight yeah we said you don't have
to go to the fight yeah that one beer so
I went to Sonoma
what the Sonoma right and then I was
like for the wedding and then we're in
wine country and then so I was just
looking at the wine list is because I'm
always knows you know always like to try
that the [ __ ] from the place and then
I'll really drink wine but they had this
IPA called plow and it was like home
brewed or whatever something like I know
why country sometimes I drink the whole
cloud that night and so did you guys
we're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] competitions no
that's weird for me I did it with
Brandon it's weird for Steve - what you
talking about
anyone here have sex in front of
everybody in the room same house yes she
thinks it's Wade like knowing that
they're connected to you you know you
said you want a drink I get like a
headache or I get sleepy and all that
this time I drink I got buzzed I didn't
really feel sick I didn't even turn red
he turned right at all you turn a little
bit but I did yeah but usually is purple
I'm usually purple like a giant bruise
and this time it was it was I just I
just got tired which I always get tired
but I wasn't able to be buzzed for like
two hours you know what probably is is
IPS have a lot more hops than the other
beers and hops are really good at
calming anxiety and back problems any
sort of like pain it kind of like is
similar to like CBD or whatever we're
really it's a drink IPAs from my back
and it really made that go away I got
into IPAs when I started dating Nikki
I'll drink more IPAs and see what
happens
hell yeah maybe because on tap - mmm
that was wine country cuz he was like
we're in wine country let me see what
beer she what cuz everyone else got wine
no take them to opto ber fence and let
him get wine I always find you guys so
[ __ ] picky but that way what you guys
like you and you but then it's so funny
cuz then we go to like [ __ ] Shinsengumi
yeah and then I'm the [ __ ] picky guy
well how am i picky no no like wouldn't
like wouldn't like when we're it's food
or whatever it is eat everything no well
no but when we're when where's the
alcohol
yeah that's true it's probably our cause
maybe it's you I don't drink no
food-wise oh you like to have certain
you like to have certain things you like
it has to be authentic I'm a foodie what
you do eat everything I need a bit like
whatever if I order whatever the way it
comes I don't go sauce on the side or
whatever I saw you're like notorious for
that no I said give me no only ice cubes
extra slice no you sure because you're
on a diet you're always like can you
substitute this yeah but that's not the
real me diet you mister Tupperware
container no the real me is like give me
the pizza and come on it but that's all
he knows so that good when we go on
Vegas we all know the real me everything
I like high quality food drink monsters
or chinko that's what I'm saying you
guys are picky budget but then I go to
the Japanese restaurant and then I'm mr.
picky pants like I'm like I'm like what
do you mean a chicken heart
am I can I just get some chicken nuggets
please no I haven't actually really good
then all thanks to be - he made me you
know what I used to do in Vegas when I
was broke
like I would I got this book called comp
City so like back in the day Vegas used
to give a bunch of free [ __ ] out like
and it's kind of like Extreme Couponing
right so then you get like these little
like freebies or you know like this
secret little casino that gives shrimp
cocktails for like 3 bucks or you get
steak and eggs for like 5 bucks and in
me my friends would just tour all that
[ __ ] and you also get free gambling like
they used to give you free money but not
before I was 21 I couldn't do that
but then when I hit around 21 I would do
that
and then they'll be like yeah $30 free
or like the first two pools free and so
we would go there we would just do that
and then go to the next casino and it
would be like a really fun Easter egg
hunt
that's sort of what they took away they
took away the free valet before you know
you go to every casino there's freedom
you got a pot you got to pay for parking
now you know what it yeah like the
economy tanked like because I remember
back in like 2006 seven like somewhere
around like 2007 eight yeah seven eight
um you you could get hotel rooms for
like thirty bucks like you still can't
appear if you're like it's like the main
casino oh really you say it's some janky
ass like Planet Fitness hotel like they
build a Vegas hotel and now they can't
sell I don't think it's that anymore I
think before word like um Vegas was like
really dirty and yucky and then they
brought a whole marketing team and then
they were like what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas so became really [ __ ]
cool and they started renovating a whole
bunch of [ __ ] and all the younger crowd
started coming in but Bellagio family it
was free like all those places Palazzo
they're all free and they're doing away
with the free alcohol to buy the slot
machines what I think they're struggling
I think I mean you're right about the
economy thing because all of that all of
those guys are making like 80 or 90
percent of their money now in China like
they opened up casinos there's a wind
there's a Bellagio there's all those
China in China of the same layout of the
Venetian of the way bad Chinese love to
gamble you love it too yeah Singapore
they charge the locals to go to the
casino like a hundred bucks because they
don't want gambling problems yeah they
don't wanna be a degenerate yeah
but Ryder don't give a [ __ ] it's part of
the good traveling here anymore so
that's the that's the thing like a lot
of the whales they're just staying in
Macau whales though the whale
casinos actually make the most amount of
money from their biggest elite players
like that's where all the big chunks
come from
so regular people like us when we walk
in we're not the we're not the people
that actually make them a lot more make
the money look you look like it yeah we
look like it until we walk to the craps
table you don't look like it
they look like it is gonna be Persian or
Asia this is what happens on it love
marry that I'm married to him because
like I'll walk into a luxury start not
to buy anything but it's just more to
like look and and it doesn't matter who
they're with as soon as they see his
face they're like oh [ __ ] money and then
they talked to us and then I thought
[ __ ] there he's American so it's like
China privilege you should talk to
Chinese oh it's almost reverse races you
know some races they walk in and they
like get calls all the gates and [ __ ]
for me they walk in they bring
everything out and they just want to
want to buy something yeah and their
eyes go to Mission but as soon as I go
excuse me where's the bathroom
wow they're like damn it he's not real
Chinese yeah it's funny though because
we have so many people and then we go up
to a table and we're like oh there's
there's 15 Domino's nothing no thank you
and we walk 2 miles so that you have to
get the deal I get videos although we do
in the most off the $10 tables that's
true that's like our sweet spot we had a
good night at the stratosphere a very
good night both those minimums dictate
how much of a heart attack you have
though playing like $5.00 like I could
play there all day and I don't really
get that gambling rush that I want but
as soon as I'm like like 15 or 20 I'm
like I feel wrong and really kill me for
me here but [ __ ] it we are like $1,000
just individually on the table if you
add everybody together that was like 10
grand on the table and then I was like
oh wow it's easier when they're chips
huh yeah I like it I like being a
responsible but you guys make me gabble
harder because you make it so fun yeah I
was by myself I think I'd be more
conservative no you're right I do
money you're welcome hey last time we
all maybe you shouldn't mean you guys
should collect the fee for that we
should call a brand new drink Alexis oh
if I lose Rancic or if I lose do you
guys give me money back you know you
played at your owners oh ok so it goes
one way but not the other almost
straight up hey Brandon to come to every
trip with me to Vegas is such a good
luck at the craps table holy did you
guys start liking gambling Nicki
introduced me to I used to play poker
though so like I started doing craps
back in 2011 but before that it was
poker it was like poker from 2007 it was
really hot around that time I remember I
turned 21 in 2007 and then I played
poker for like until a certain Vegas
trip and then that Vegas trip I switched
over to craps cuz it was so much fun
cuz before it craps looks intimidating
but if you actually like Lara is so easy
though most people like blackjack I
always lose that blackjack so I never
played it perhaps is also more inclusive
you could have all your friends come and
everyone's on the same team yeah that's
why if there's like one person with bad
juju you're like oh cool craps table is
always one yeah he's a cool guy who's
like everyone's cheering on Mike Jim
he's like he's like he's like I'm too
cool way to write besides Vegas we're
all so do we all travel together why we
were just having that Congress Atlantis
please another gambling spots too and
there's a beach why do you want to go
there so bad because it's everything
I've ever won on every vacation
all-in-ones what is it give me give it
to me it's got a huge water park-like
acres and acres of water park there's a
mile-long lazy river and you just keep
circling around and if you're like oh
[ __ ] I want a cocktail there's like
places where you pull off the lazy river
you just grab a cocktail you just keep
on oh you're describing what a [ __ ]
upgraded Vegas is with the boat around
it's Vegas with good weather I'm just
getting started though okay it's on a
[ __ ] island like Hawaii like where
there's a nice accent [ __ ] Beach
salad baby so the dream snorkeling its
wife's baby cause you gotta buy the
[ __ ] clothes I'm just saying I need
to go there before I get pregnant so
hurry the [ __ ] up everybody where is
this it's in the Bahamas Oh
Jabez and then and then there's a casino
and then like there's swim up
casino games in like the [ __ ] pools
okay we are chips already was very
buoyant very buoyant chips not that
[ __ ] be vague and you can if you
have a big enough group you can rent a
boat for the day and Glaus snorkeling
not don't invite David Doody we've got
the worst [ __ ] day that's pretty fun
even in Hawaii right now
that's why he's not here and it's
[ __ ] raining in Hawaii
that's his [ __ ] there's a hurricane hey
you know what though we won when David
wasn't around at the craps tables oh you
know we got to keep the [ __ ] away and
saw the stench out in New York City we
bought singing here you go he's like you
guys all cover yeah yeah he was the
worst luck every time you can the table
we start early I saw from a mile away
with a big grin walking toward me and
I'm all like
happy that we like honed in on Sean
whose rules stand there and like we'd be
winning and then he'd go up to the table
and everyone just started lose what's
happening because I think I missed one
gambling session with you guys so then I
join you guys we're having a good old
time and I see Sean happy I was like
young Sean come on in and all of you
guys like no he's like because this is
money
I remember Bart Bart would always do
this thing where he would he would have
his chips and he would watch you and
he'd see if you're worthy of him
doubling down the back yeah and then as
soon as you walk he would like drop the
chip to like double down his bed or like
feel the energy of the table and I'm
like what's gonna happen right now and
then sometimes I get it but the table
was losing that would be kind of cool
cuz like I was we were talking about
this on a drive up sister Nova we're
like then it would be really cool if we
take another trip and like what we did
with Japan and it was kind of like
culture shock II for a lot of people
because we've never experienced any of
that so I was trying to think of other
places Thailand yeah Thailand or I was
thinking like India too would be like
super cool and you would be cool or
Costa Rica you know what would be really
culture shock II Syria together I love
that that's a that that got a laugh
right now maybe someone's watch this is
serious [ __ ] would you guys be done it
sense of humor that's how they watch it
that's true we love you guys would you
guys be down to do it off off the grid
off the grid trip what's that
so like burn to resort well no so you
find out you you find you you pretty
much drive like on a freeway somewhere
you got a map out your course but then
you drive off the freeway where there's
no pre paved roads and you just do like
kinda like a back roads little tour
through ever you doesn't do any camping
or any you know there's no Wi-Fi signal
is the end destination of the night it's
like a hotel
maybe after eight days Navi then I'm
down that's how people die and then it's
a JK article and Tim is like JK dues
members died because they didn't have
Wi-Fi
we don't was gonna interrupt there
though she's gonna get the story just
hurt maybe not one time we got to work
up to that because oh yeah I don't know
maybe it's just you that can survive and
knows how to do it know though we'd
bring a cooler a grill but it's just it
forces you it's like going camping but
you're just going camping when there's a
play there's no running water
you know what words I don't like it
balls in a vacation forces you I'm like
doesn't exist encourage encourage you so
you can't go on Wi-Fi oh no no no you
can't well but highly encourages you did
not go on Wi-Fi this is a good time I
don't go try to take me geocaching have
you heard of that I know it is that so
people like take little GPS is and they
put it in like a Tupperware container
and then people like put it on a map on
a big map on the internet that everyone
can go get and you go geocaching that
weekend which is when you just go and
you use your GPS to find the Jeep yes
you should put a prize there and it's
like a it's like a sport something
people do for fun but I found out during
this during nine hours of this that is
not fun
I had an ex-boyfriend that used to jog
with his dad he was really cool too oh
my god oh yeah hunting trip and and live
in the wild okay I'm out
yeah I'm out to you and Bart can go do
that is there a water slide there like
I know what sentence what's the cool
thing of a lazy river nature yeah nature
in the woods and just relax
I'd be crying the whole time that's what
I'm saying go to Deep Creek it's so fun
it's like it's like off-road like
where's that Atlantis I know it's on the
way to Vegas it's like and you have to
stay you camp at this place called Bowen
ranch or whatever wherever you want to
camp then you have to hike 45 minutes
down to this river that also has natural
built-in hot springs and it's like three
levels of hot springs cool and and it's
but it's also a nudist colony it goes
there there's not that many nudists and
you don't have to be nude but staying at
the Bellagio there's a natural built-in
jacuzzi that's all built-in buffet you
don't hike 45 minutes either it's very
it's very nature and in the summertime
it's cool because the river is really
cold and the hot springs are hot so like
you go in the river and then go but I
don't want neighbors that's the thing
the reason why the off the grid it's
you're not you're not an account site
next to another campsite next another
campsite
you're just out with a rifle and my dog
is just walking around roaming free and
then yeah I pitch a tent and sleep and I
see the Sun Rise give me that bird I can
see the sunrise from the 19th floor at
7:00 a.m. when you're done gambling yeah
exactly you don't have neighbors at this
place though like you if there's other
notice colonies or no no no they like go
there during the daytime but they stay
down there like you knew hiked up to the
ranch I don't I just want to improve
doing really far away said I don't do
normally you never been to no Bahamas
yeah but it's it's just it's Vegas but
with tropics you know like I mean it's
dope I'm not I'm not knocking it the two
things that you love the most
yeah I'm just saying I'm Duncan I'm down
to do that but I'm also down to do the
complete opposite of living in the mud -
you know what's still you have this
freaking schmuck Catelli that's down a
go with you so make it a honeymoon hey
you guys should go to Australia where
the most things in the world can kill
you
I'm doubt that - it sounds interesting
my god I love watching a Tara Dara
Brothers what supernovas that one
they're just these two brothers that
live in the outback and they run around
and they catch snakes and frogs and they
eat them in snow
there you go that's how you'll meet up
with them do you like that you want that
is that reason that's not yeah it looks
it looks delicious there you go folks
there you go
I want to all-you-can-eat buffet 2495
and I sit there for Italy throw me out I
don't want that I like experiencing
different foods of different places yeah
that's what you do a buffet I had the
Chinese through the local Vegas people
chefs from all over the world to the
buffet do you understand that's what we
hate KC and I hated staying in Cancun
because we had an all-inclusive Resort
and then all the food was included none
of it was a traditional authentic
Mexican I like random so like yeah the
worst food I'm even like food to exact
what does that say about that place when
most people travel though majority of
people they just want to eat what
they're used to just like most you know
Asian parents want to eat their home
food and then like you know and like
white parents usually they stay at the
resort and then they want their
hamburgers and they don't want to go off
and discover things that I'm trying to
get diarrhea yeah that's a really small
group of people that's when we
discovered we will never stay in
all-inclusive yeah that's for people
that want to go to like kind of do it
you guys should be on the show survivor
because you already do all the physical
like mosquito bites well what do you
think camping in the freaking no that's
in between you can't say all this [ __ ]
you've been talking to them say you
don't like Miss Caroline Luffy confused
that in between I want to be off the
grid right and yeah so I have no Wi-Fi
but I have books breaks I mean he has
his truck he has a sleeping bag survivor
playing that phrase yeah truck you can
win bug spray are you competitive
another survivor is a [ __ ] leather
loincloth and you have a [ __ ] no it's
like poisonous frogs biting your boss
there's no leather they have team flag
Jersey or you're thinking of naked and
afraid
oh yeah that's survivor you're on like
you're in camps you're like in teams all
I could do that that's like jakey
party but also reflects that on the show
making it afraid about that on the show
and I don't even know who they are they
were like famous youtuber and I quit the
[ __ ] is that hey they don't know who you
are either pal I know I didn't know the
show shall be listed as a famous
youtuber
oh we know a friend that went on
Survivor Oh Mari she went she did yeah
oh she did how did she do mari from
Smosh I don't know any watch it we will
have to see it
I thought Survivor was over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]